За даними українського уряду, за кордоном лише на постійній основі
працює понад три мільйони громадян України.
Точна кількість заробітчан невідома, адже ніхто
не знає, скільки з них працює неофіційно.
За оцінками експертів, через пандемію коронавірусу
в Україну повернулися до 300 тисяч заробітчан.
Президент Володимир Зеленський у недавньому відеозверненні
висловив надію, що вони і після карантину залишаться на батьківщині.
Зараз в Україну повернулося дуже багато громадян з-за кордону.
Це добра новина, нехай і обставини такого повернення не найприємніші.
Але рано чи пізно коронавірус обов'язково пройде, і карантин закінчиться.
Вважаю, що ми повинні зробити все і втримати цих людей на батьківщині.
Нам дуже потрібні ваші знання та ваші вміння.
Натомість експерти з міжнародного працевлаштування вважають,
що забезпечити роботою сотні тисяч людей, багато з яких не мають відповідної кваліфікації, - нереально.
Більшість трудових мігрантів, які зараз повертаються,
не зможуть інтегруватися в нашу економіку.
Вони не зможуть знайти роботу з високою заробітною платою.
Все залежатиме від того, які фахівці повертаються.
В Україні зараз не вистачає зварювальників, людей, які працюють на сучасному обладнанні.
І такі фахівці, я впевнений, зможуть знайти для себе місце.
Проте їхня кількість відносно невелика, і вони не змінять
загальних тенденцій на ринку працевлаштування.
Більшість заробітчан, що повернулися, неохоче спілкуються зі ЗМІ.
Дехто з них боїться звинувачень у тому, що вони нібито привезли в країну коронавірус.
А дехто взагалі не хоче зайвий раз розповідати про роботу на чужині.
Утім, за допомогою відеозв'язку нам вдалося поспілкуватися
з кількома українцями, які нещодавно повернулися із заробітків.
Стефанії Шуповал з Тернополя - 58 років. 20 із них вона працює в Італії.
Останнім часом їздить туди за кількамісячними контрактами "баданткою"
- доглядає за людьми похилого віку. На такій роботі
можна заробити майже 1000 євро на місяць.
В Україну Стефанія повернулася наприкінці лютого.
Переживає, що кордони не відкриють, адже в червні вона знову має їхати на заробітки.
Я не маю пенсії в Україні.
І не знаю, чи отримаю,
бо я стільки років перебувала за кордоном,
що у мене стажу тільки 22 роки.
Щоб в Україні отримати пенсію, я ще замолода,
а щоб прийняли мене на роботу, то я застара.
Значить, мені потрібно їхати за кордон, щоб жити.
Я ж не буду...
щоб діти мене утримували - це ще зарано.
Якщо не відкриють кордони і я не зможу поїхати в Італію,
я маю намір знайти роботу в Україні. Наприклад,
доглядати людей похилого віку.
Я маю практику, значить, зможу працювати.
Я зараз стараюся економити ті гроші, які за три місяці заробила,
щоб мені вистачило на прожиття, заплатити за комунальні послуги.
А далі я сподіваюся, що все-таки поїду.
Тому що в іншому разі я залишуся без нічого.
Людмила Стрільчук з села Горопаї на Житомирщині
вже два рази їздила працювати у Польщу на меблевій фабриці.
Хотіла заробити доньці на весілля.
20 березня разом із подругою повернулася в Україну.
Каже, якщо кордони не відкриють, це буде "катастрофа".
Під час нашої розмови Людмила перебувала на самоізоляції.
Це буде катастрофа. Якщо кордон не відкриють, нам буде дуже важко.
Я не знаю, як ми будемо жити, як ми виживемо. Я цього не знаю.
Чоловік одержує п'ять тисяч в місяць.
А корова як отелиться - молоко здаємо, це ще десь тисяча в місяць. Такий дохід у нас.
Ми заробляли 3200 злотих у місяць. На меблевій фабриці працювали, робили меблі.
Треба вертатися, бо в нас нема де заробляти і в нас нема за що жити.
На п'ять тисяч не виживеш у нас. Треба буде вертатися, якщо відкриють кордони.
У Польщі нас не звільнили - ми самі поїхали.
Але роботодавець сказав: якщо кордони відкриють і все налагодиться,
щоб ми приїжджали назад. Вони на нас чекають у Польщі.
18-річний Арсен Сагінадзе вивчає готельно-ресторанну справу
у Запорізькому національному університеті.
Пандемія застала Арсена в Берліні, куди він на три місяці влаштувався працювати в готель.
В Україну повернувся у середині березня.
Після карантину хоче знову поїхати до Німеччини.
Я працював у галузі хаускіпінга в готелі. Це прибирання номерів.
Насправді це дуже хороша можливість і заробити грошей, і подивитися країну.
Але знову ж таки: через всю цю ситуацію я не заробив, а навпаки - втратив гроші.
Я хотів заплатити за своє навчання,
допомогти родині і щось на себе витратити -
на одяг, відпочинок, можливо, купити новий телефон.
У Німеччину я приїхав на початку лютого.
Коли в Берліні з'явилася перша заражена людина,
тоді вже потроху почалася паніка, і готелі вже зазнавали збитків.
А потім мені мій шеф просто написав, що він дуже шкодує, але всі готелі групи закривають.
Якщо прийде запрошення від мого роботодавця, я б із задоволенням ще раз поїхав у Берлін.
Ірина Лагодяк з міста Сторожинець Чернівецької області
доглядає за 91-річною жінкою на півночі Італії.
Попри пандемію вона вирішила залишитися, хоча дуже сумує за мамою в Україні.
Моїй мамі 82 роки.
І вона просила, щоб я приїхала додому.
Але я вирішила не їхати, я не хотіла везти цю біду своїм рідним в Україну.
У нас, мабуть, у кожній третій сім’ї хтось за кордоном.
Якщо не в Італії, то в Іспанії, Португалії, Бельгії.
З Чернівецької області дуже багато людей за кордоном.
Я зараз у дуже хорошій сім’ї, вони дуже переживають за нас.
Завжди питають, як мої діти в Україні, як моя мама в Україні.
Завдяки роботі в Італії ми допомогли своїм сім’ям.
І ремонти зробили, а якщо не було будинків, то побудували будинки.
Люди допомогли своїм дітям.
Покоління наших дітей, я думаю, вже не поїде за кордон,
не буде в наймах, як ми поїхали в свій час.
Вагомим є також внесок українських заробітчан в економіку країни в цілому.
За оцінками Національного банку, вони лише у 2019 році
переказали на батьківщину майже 12 мільярдів доларів.
А на нестачу робочих рук з України через перекриття кордонів
на час карантину вже скаржаться у країнах ЄС.